GETTING SUED:
By now, I’m sure you’ve heard about
Amazon getting sued. The FTC and 17 states have
sued Amazon for maintaining an illegal monopoly
within the e-commerce market. The outcome of this
case could very well be Amazon getting split up
into not just 2 companies but several companies.
Also, it’s not just Amazon that would be affected
as this case would very much set a precedent for
all of big tech in general, potentially leading
to even more breakups and landmark cases. The idea
of Amazon finally being held accountable has made
much of the internet quite happy because let’s
be honest, Amazon is definitely a monopoly. Last
year, nearly 60% of all online retail purchases
were made on Amazon. If that’s not a monopoly,
I don’t know what is. But, this doesn’t have to be
bad news for Amazon. In fact, this lawsuit could
turn into the best thing that ever happened to
Amazon. Here’s the thing, whether you or me or the
entire world believes that Amazon is a monopoly is
for the most part completely irrelevant. All that
matters is whether that argument actually holds
up within the court of law. And let me just say,
Amazon has a far better chance at court than they
do with public opinion. As Amazon put it while
it’s true that most online retail purchases come
through them, they don't exactly end up with them.
In fact, Amazon claims that they’re supporting
500,000 independent businesses and 1.5 million
jobs within the US alone. With that being said,
Amazon would’ve definitely preferred for this case
to never come up in the first place but at the
same time they likely knew that it was inevitable
and they can very much use it in their favor.
Here’s the thing, if Amazon is able to come out
on top with this case, no prosecutor would likely
touch them for the next 20-30 years. In other
words, winning this case would basically give them
a free pass to keep doing exactly what they’re
doing with little fear of legal repercussions.
Don’t believe me? Well join me as we take a
look back at a few landmark cases that show that
this case could just as easily go Amazon’s way.
MICROSOFT GOT AWAY:
Speaking of monopolies,
if you’d like to help us take on the big bank
monopoly and earn 4-7% yields in the meantime,
check out our upcoming bond investing app
Silo in the description below. But anyway,
getting straight into it, if you’ve been watching
this channel for a while, you probably alread know
what case I’m gonna talk about. It’s none other
than the landmark case United States vs Microsoft.
If you’re not familiar with this case, this
was probably before your time but essentially,
this case was a daring bid to break up Microsoft
into 2 companies: one that sold operating systems
and one that sold other pieces of software
like Internet Explorer, Microsoft Office,
MSN Messenger and so on. The roots of this case
date back to mid 1990s when the internet was just
starting to become a thing. The go to browser
for 90% of internet users was something called
Netscape Navigator. So, they were very much a
monopoly which Microsoft wasn’t exactly a fan of.
You may not have known this but these companies
only like it when they’re the monopoly. So,
on August 16, 1995, Microsoft decided to take
things into their own hands by launching Internet
Explorer. Given Microsoft’s resources, putting
together a functional browser wasn’t particularly
hard but getting people to use it, man, that
was difficult. But fortunately, Microsoft had
a sneaky plan to get around this little conundrum.
Everyone already had Windows computers, so what if
Microsoft just bundled in Internet Explorer with
Windows? That should give IE a massive boost in
popularity straight out the gate right? Well,
there was just one fatal flaw with this plan:
it was illegal. You see, the DOJ had already seen
this coming. They saw Microsoft do it with Office
and they had since put a deal in place that
would prevent Microsoft from ever doing it
again. There was one caveat to this deal though.
Microsoft wasn’t allowed to bundle in products
with Windows but they were allowed to bundle in
features. So, they would just call IE feature and
bundle it in with Windows. Obviously, everyone in
the entire world knows that IE is a product and
that this is in violation of their previous DOJ
settlement. But, Microsoft probably just thought,
we can roll the dice with an anti trust lawsuit
if it ever came to it. And guess what, it would
come to it. On May 18, 1998, the DOJ and 20 states
would file an antitrust lawsuit against Microsoft
just like what we’re seeing right now with Amazon.
The case would drag on for about 2 years and both
Microsoft and the DOJ would have their own share
of victories and losses but at the end of the day,
the DOJ would prevail. On June 7, 2000, Microsoft
would officially be ordered to split up into 2
different companies. Most people thought that this
was the end of it. Microsoft was a monopoly. They
knew it, the DOJ knew, the whole world knew it,
and now it was made official and it was time for
Microsoft to face the music. Unfortunately though,
it didn’t end up playing out like this. Instead,
Microsoft would appeal to the Supreme Court and
they would end up overturning this decision over
a legal technicality. You see, the judge that was
overseeing the case had regularly made statements
on the media because the public wanted to stay
up to date. And Microsoft would end up arguing
that his statements to the media suggested that
he was biased against Microsoft. The Supreme
Court would rule that the judge’s findings and
conclusions were all well and good. However,
due to apparent bias, his final ruling was not.
As such, Microsoft would be allowed to settle.
Let me put this another way. The DOJ literally
proved that Microsoft was a monopoly in court
and Microsoft still wasn’t broken up because of
legal technicality that likely not even Microsoft
cared about. As far as they were concerned, this
was just a loophole to get out the situation and
it worked. Fast forward 23 years and not only
is Microsoft 10 times bigger but they’re still
bundling in Edge with Windows. So, just because a
massive case is filed against Amazon doesn’t mean
anything. As far as we know, a judge could point
blank rule for Amazon to be broken up and it could
still go the other way. Until they’re actually
broken up, they’re not. But, even on the off
chance that they do get broken, it probably
wont matter all that much. Let me explain.
BREAK UPS DON’T MATTER:
A lot of people seem to think
that breaking up a monopoly such as Amazon is
exactly the solution we need. But, in reality,
this isn’t all that effective; in fact, I would
argue that it’s for the most part ineffective and
we’ve seen this repeatedly throughout history,
starting with Standard Oil. Standard Oil was the
brainchild of oil pioneer John D Rockefeller
and it was definitely a monopoly. Going into
the 1900s, Standard oil controlled 91% of oil
production and 85% of final sales in the United
States. So, in 1906, Uncle Sam decided to step
in and teach Standard Oil a lesson. The case
would drag on for 5 years but eventually
prosecutors would get their way. In 1911,
Standard Oil would be split up into not just 1 or
2 or even 5 companies. They would be split up into
34 separate entities. Surely, such drastic action
would neutralize the company because they would
have to compete against each other right? Well,
it actually did the exact opposite. You see, the
leaders of these companies may have had internal
conflicts amongst themselves before the split up
but after the split up, they were more united
than ever. The situation had changed from you
vs me to us vs the world. This was also around the
time that the Ford Model T would go viral meaning
that more people needed oil than ever before.
And instead of fighting over these customers,
Standard Oil companies would unite and dominate
and the market together. Investors would do the
exact same thing. Now that the antitrust
cloud wasn’t looming over Standard Oil,
investors would be far more willing to
invest. And if you don’t believe me,
just look at the facts. In the 10 years that
followed the break up, the combined value of
the 34 companies didn’t just grow, it quintupled.
This took Rockefeller from being a mere mortal
worth $300 million to being the world’s first
billionaire. The irony of that is insane. The
case that was supposed to put a decisive end
to people like Rockefeller literally ended
up creating the world’s first billionaire. And it
doesn’t just stop right there either. Eventually,
the strongest of these companies would make their
partnerships official and merge to create Exxon,
Chevron, and BP. Over a 100 years after the
break up, these 3 are all still part of the
top 10 oil companies with a combined market value
of just under a trillion dollars. You might be
inclined to say that this was just a fluke and
that Standard Oil just got lucky which brings
us into our next landmark lawsuit: United States
vs AT&T. Back in the 1970s, AT&T found themselves
controlling 90% of the US telephone business.
Seeing this, Uncle Sam decided that it was time
to put an end to this disgusting monopoly. After
an 8 year lawsuit, in 1982, AT&T would agree to
split up their business into 7 smaller regional
businesses called “Baby Bells”. Surely, this
would pit these companies against each other and
lead to a competitive landscape. But, once again,
the exact opposite happened. The Baby Bells would
end up joining forces in record time. Here’s a
flowchart of exactly what happened. The Baby Bells
would basically just unite to create AT&T and
Verizon, the two players who still dominate the US
telecommunications industry to this day. I do want
to note that T Mobile was able make a name for
themselves during this time period but it wasn’t
because of the breaup. It was because there was
a new market: wireless telecommunications which
allowed for new competition to capitlize on. Not
to mention, T Mobile was backed by the German
telecommunications monopoly: Deutsche Telekom. So,
it wasn’t really a case of an underdog taking on
Verizon and AT&T. It was actually just a case of
an international monopoly taking on 2 national
monopolies and together, they still control
the entire market. So, who knows? Breaking up
Amazon may actually play out better for Amazon
over the long term. Instead of being worth a
mere $150 billion, Jeff Bezos could become the
world’s first trillionaire. Jokes aside though,
just like an antitrust lawsuit isn’t necessarily
a nail in the coffin, a break up isn’t either.
AMAZON’S ADVANTAGE:
At the end of the day, Amazon is
a trillion dollar corporation and you can bet that
they’re gonna show up to court with the absolute
best lawyers in the world. But not only are they
skilled, they’ll be far more incentivized to win.
Federal prosecutors are at best paid a $183,000
for their efforts. So, winning has more to do
with principle and the justice of taking down
the bully than monetary gain. Amazon’s lawyers,
on the other hand, are literally paid tens of
millions and you can bet that they’re gonna get a
ridiculous $50 or $100 million bonus if they’re
able to come out victorious. Not to mention,
history has shown us that it’s extremely
difficult to break up one of these companies.
They don’t even need to prove that they’re not a
monopoly. Even a legal technicality is enough to
through out the entire case regardless of their
guilt. And with this much at stake, who knows
what Amazon’s lawyers will uncover. But, even
if they lose and Amazon somehow gets broken up,
it doesn’t really matter all that much anyway. All
of Amazon’s investors including Jeff Bezos will
just own both companies which could allow them to
grow to even larger heights. None of this is to
say that Amazon is destined to be a monopoly
forever though. In fact, Jeff Bezos would be
the first one to admit that Amazon isn’t gonna
last forever. But monopolies like Amazon aren’t
taken down by litigation or government action.
Monopolies are a monopoly for a reason. It’s
not because these companies are so smart or they
have so much power or any of that. It’s because
their current value in the marketplace is simply
indispensable. Splitting up such company won’t
change that. The only way that such monopolies
are destroyed is by an extreme market shift: when
the next revolutionary shopping platform comes out
and Amazon is no longer indispensible. Until then,
any noise like this lawsuit can’t really hurt them
whether it’s successful or not. If anything, it
just gives them an opportunity to clear their name
and double down. With these types of lawsuits,
the public is usually rooting against the
big tech company. But, not too long ago,
the public was actually rooting for Google to win
a lawsuit. Check out this video to learn more.